I think the goal of poetry is to evoke a
common experience among readers I think
that the the power of the written word
the written word when used for the
purposes of arresting the body mind is
to alter our consciousness poetic
rapture is really more like a trance
it's a place you go it's a hypnotic
state it's a fusion of cognition and
dream and the poetic trance is very
interesting to me it's not just when we
read poetry it's also when we get caught
up in a beautiful song when we lose
ourselves in a movie or when we find
ourselves tumbling down the rabbit hole
in some kind of mediated environment and
all of a sudden we experience what in VR
terms is called presence it's that sense
of immersion that sense of moving into a
different world Janet Marie and her book
Hamlet on the holodeck refers to this
immersive state as a threshold state the
word for threshold is actually
liminality so she says that we go into
this liminal trance that she also
describes as mythopoetic which I love
that it blends the terms mythology and
poetry to this idea of a mythopoetic
state a missle poetic place in the mind
a mythopoetic perception that makes you
be here it makes you be now but it
actually also curls or rather like
impregnates the now with a cosmic wink
and certain during those moments of
poetic rhapsody wherever we are and
whatever you're doing becomes Rhian
chanted you know if the aesthetics match
the mood you enter into radiance you
walk into the light and I think these
mystical States are the ones that
shamans and wise men and spiritualists
have been talking about since the
beginning of time I think even the
origins of the world's religions lie in
these mythopoetic trances that were
catalyzed that were staged either by
psychotropics or by painting in the
caves or by dancing around the fire we
had early psychoactive technologies to
alter our perceptions and enter into
radiance and during radiance during
these immersive mythopoetic
trance States
during the poetic trance oh my god we
become like Willie and Blake we see the
world oh my god in a grain of sand we
see heaven in a wild flower we hold
infinity in the palms of our hands and
we hold eternity in an hour so it's like
the poetic rapture induces xed asses we
go outside ourselves and beyond
ourselves to connect with something
greater than ourselves and again that's
the common experience that poetry seeks
to evoke because it's connected to what
can only be born in the human heart it's
it's sort of the deeper picture of what
we think we are and why we're here and
what we're here to do the poetic trance
is a glimpse of what lies just beyond
the ordinary and every day and I think
therein lies the answer to the mystery
of being and I think that's why we keep
going back there
erling ourselves into these blissful
mind-body states of ecstasy of the
poetic trance and I certainly know that
for me my videos in my media are really
an excuse to stage that my own spiritual
interventions my own way of rippling and
Dancing with the universe and warping
space and time around me through these
technological mediation and Nirvana
inducing in Nirvana inducing mythopoetic
trance States is is is is why I film why
I make videos why I come to places like
this it means to get there you got to go
there to get there you know what I mean
you